[موسيقى]
يمكن النظر للتجارب الاوروبيه وهي تجارب
ينبغي الاعتبار منها التجربه الالمانيه
مثلا وهي المثال الابرز هنا فقد اتخذ
المستشاران السابقان قيرهالشرايدر وانجلا
ميركل سياسات مدمره لسياده الالمانيه برفض
بناء موانئ وايضا المصافي والاتجاه صوب
الطاقه الخضراء العقيده والنتيجه المانيا
اصبحت رهينه للسياسات الروسيه
لقد كانت سياسه غبيه وخرقاء كررها فريق
يحييط بجوبايدن في الولايات المتحده
وقاده هذا الوضع بلادنا الى ان يضطر وفقا
لصحيفه
بمن فيهم وزيره الخزانات جانات يلين الى
تقديم طلب عاجل لمنتجيا النفط بمن فيهما
السعوديه لتاجيل القرار لمده شهر اخر
[موسيقى]
اخبر ممثل بعيد عن المملكه العربيه
السعوديه انهم اذا وافقوا على التاجيل فان
الولايات المتحده ستشتري النفط من السوق
الدوليه لتجديد احتياطي البترول
الاستراتيجيه الامريكي الذي استنفذ الان
الى مستوى قياسيا منخفض لم نشهده منذ عام
85 9000 لكن ذلك يتزامن ايضا مع استغلال
النفوذ الاجنبي من قبل اطراف
ايضا عبر نجليه في مجال المصالح النفطيه
الاجنبيه وقد تفاقم مؤخرا حيث هناك مثلا
تحقيقات تشمل عمليه بيع غريبه لما يقربوا
من مائه مليون برميل من النفط الثمين من
الاحتياط البترولي الامريكي الى شركه
صينيه هو الجمهوريون عندما سيستعيدون
الاغلبيه سيسرعون التحقيقات بشان ذلك وحتى
نائبه الرئيس هناك ما اخذ كثيرا على
ادائها والحزب الديمقراطيه يمر بوضع سيء
جدا
[موسيقى]